pendant ce temps l'exode des réfugiés
lui se poursuit on peut parler de crise
humanitaire au moins 360 8000 ukrainiens
sont réfugiés dans les pays limitrophes
depuis le début du conflit armé selon le
hcr la hongrie la moldavie la slovaquie
la pologne ou encore la roumanie face à
l'afflux de réfugiés se tient un conseil
des ministres européens de l'intérieur
cet après midi à bruxelles on retrouve
tout de suite laxmi l'hôte à notre
correspondante sur place quel est
l'objectif de cette réunion des
ministres de l'intérieur
alors les ministres de l'intérieur de
ligne de l'union serait une liste en ce
moment même ils vont parler de la
gestion de l'aide humanitaire mais aussi
vous le disiez de l'accueil de ces
réfugiés qui continuent à arriver au
sein de l'union et de la protection des
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne selon l'organisation des
nations unies plus de trois cent mille
personnes ont déjà fui l'ukraine et la
crise pourrait provoquer le déplacement
de 5 millions de réfugiés les pays
membres de l'union européenne promettent
de les aider alors pour l'instant l'aide
se concentrent vers les pays en première
ligne de cet accueil des réfugiés à
savoir la pologne mais aussi dans une
moindre mesure pour l'instant la hongrie
la slovaquie et la roumanie l'allemagne
a déjà dit qu'elle était prête à aider
massivement ses voisins la france dit
qu'elle fera sa part les européens sont
pour le moment solidaire est l'occasion
pour les européens de définir une
politique commune
alors oui une autre réunion une deuxième
réunion du virtuel cette fois est prévue
en début de soirée cette fois ce sont
elles les ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'union qui vont se voir
en vidéo conférence ils vont évoquer la
logistique comment faire parvenir
correctement les moyens de défense les
armes a mises à la disposition de
l'ukraine ils vont évoquer la logistique
concernant l'aide humanitaire également
la diplomatie européenne va aussi abordé
les quelles sanctions contre la russie
il s'agira de les adopter l'allemagne
cette fois et pour la déconnexion du
réseau bancaire swift déconnexion de la
russie car la mesure est ciblée elle
concerne certaines banques russes
uniquement l'objectif de ces nouvelles
sanctions est véritablement de limiter
les capacités financières russes
financière pour pour cette guerre en
ukraine merci beaucoup laxmi lota
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous